[музыка]
планирование это очень важная часть моей
жизни это моё хобби
я люблю заниматься планированием я даже
финансирует дым стартап который
оптимизирует систему планирования
позже в конце самые к презентации я вам
дам несколько приложений которые вам
облегчат планирования в айфоне я сейчас
уже на бумаге не планирую в айфоне но я
вам рекомендую начать с бумажной
с простой версии час планирование это
равен 10 дня работы и примерно она так и
выходит
час планирование час качественном
планировали равен как минимум я я бы
добавил бы как минимум десяти дням
просто простой работы без планирования
какие сегодня есть систем планирования
вам тоже покажу и их недостатки тоже
покажу итак приступаем у нас к 1 планеты
как основа счастливой жизни какие топике
мы сегодня пройдём ну первое изречение
ричарда баха на это читали
джонатан дэвис тон чайка по имени
джонатан ливингстон такие серию книг у
него философских вот он пишет вам
никогда не дается мечта
без ресурсов и сил для ее осуществления
если у вас есть мечта она просто так не
приходит значит у вас есть и будут
ресурсы и силы для того чтобы ее
осуществить просто ваша задача найти их
эти ресурсы и силы сегодня мы пройдем
что такое икигай вкратце потому что их
игра это как нахождение смысла жизни но
это понимать это не одна лекция этого
очень долго но и открыться пройдут что
такое к 1 планирование и его отличие от
списка дел и от прочих систем
планирования
принципы планирования правила системы
планирования и ati приложений для
организации системы планирования я не
стал всё выводить на слайды больше чтобы
устно общаться разъяснять говорите так
далее вот что такое икигай вот есть
такое хорошее понятие японской культуре
икигай это икигай то ради чего ты живешь
ради чего ты утром просыпаешься новости
вкратце говорить но если говорить более
длинное это твое предназначение в жизни
для чего ты пришел в эту жизнь это по
сути смысл то что мы говорим в чем смысл
жизни
японцы ввели это термины этот термин
происходит с острова окинава грина и
борщ и колесе долгожителей и они во
главу угла своей жизни ставят нахождение
своего икигай
вот у японцев есть такое хорошее понятие
как у них шабунин это мастер своего дела
это высшее мастерство его дело это когда
двор не хочет стать лучшим дворником в
мире он не хочет стать начальником
отдела дворников начальник департамента
дворников начальником компании
дворникова хочешь быть лучшим дворником
в мире если это певец вам хочет быть
лучшим певцом в мире и вот каждый в
своем направлении но чтобы стать шакуни
нам ты не обязательно должен найти свой
икигай
и вот три понятия шакуни приняты на
хочет икигай потом процессе его
становишься шакуни нам и когда
выполняешь работу ты получаешь
достигаешь точки сатори это точка
наибольшего блаженства или поток где ты
чувствуешь себя счастливым и вот что
такое не кикает вот мне нравится
высказанный виктора франкла вам пишет
счастье вызнать виктор франкл это
психолог которые пережил освенцим кучу
концлагерей
остался живым потом начнем работать
практикующим психологом и детям
преподавал
так вот он пишет счастье это всего лишь
побочный эффект правильно организованной
жизни отсюда хороший вывод если у вас
жизнь бар дачная она не будь счастливой
вот вы должны четко понимать что
равенство знак равенства счастье и
правильно организовано жизнь это равно
знак равенства
если у вас жизнь бар дачное у вас
никогда счастье не будет что-то выбор
дачная жизнь
это непредвиденные случайности это
разные нежданчики неприятные сюрпризы
это непредсказуемость и неуправляемость
своей жизни вы чувствуете что жизнь вам
не управляется и вы чувствуете себя
щепкой в этой реке жизни соответственно
откуда в вас будет счастье счастье есть
еще другое такое определение это степень
контроля вами своей жизни
но это переключатель перекликается со
словами
виктора франкла что счастье это всего
лишь побочный эффект правильно
организованной жизни если у вас будет
правильно организованная жизнь то
счастье придет к вам как побочный эффект
теперь приемкой и саму икигай и кикать
состоит из четырех кружков первый круг
это называется люблю делать
люблю делать вы должны для себя я потом
объясню по насколько это важно и она как
каракаре льюис планирования дело в том
что забегая вперед скажу что для того
чтобы добиться счастливой жизни вы
должны планировать правильные вещи если
вы не знаете для чего вы вообще живете
вы запланируете неправильные вещи а
самое худшее в этой жизни эффективно
делать то что не нужно делать для того
чтобы выделить
а что же тогда нужно делать для этого
вам нужно ответить на вопрос избегать
что вы любите делать
берете список и пишите просто тупо этот
список и пишите я люблю вот это я люблю
вот это я люблю вот это я люблю
написали второе что я умею делать дело в
том что есть вещи которые мы любим а
есть вещи которые мы умеем делать я я бы
еще переиначил чуть-чуть не то что я вам
и идет а что у меня хорошо получается
потому что часто бывает так как какое-то
время 100 человек умеет делать но у него
плохо получается ну где-то не придет там
как анекдот про лучшего преферансе ством
мире ему просто карта не прет он при
финансиста самый лучший в мире просто
карточный трюк но такое бывает поэтому
нужно больше концерта не то чтобы мне
идет а что у меня хорошо получается
дальше то что за за что мне платят
тоже надо описать дальше что нужно людям
и вот когда 4 вот этих объединяется у
вас получается между люблю делать и умею
делать это страсть
хобби между умею делать это что за что
платят эта работа между туда что платят
и что нужно людям это призвание
между то что людям нужно лишь любви от
этом месте и вот центре киева
это такой sweet spot если его
делайте вы вы и вам хорошо платят и это
нужно людям и вы это любите и у вас это
хорошо получаете но что-то не
заморачиваться на этом я чуть угу
простил и нашёл вот такую вещь вот это
проще потому что вот то что тебя
зажигает то что ты умеешь это что
кому-то нужно потому что то что людям
нужно это что за что тебе платят
обычно это на самом деле это одно и то
же то что если людям это нужно то как
правило тебе за это платят поэтому чтобы
не усложнять схему вот я взяла вот такую
схему
то что тебя зажигают или то что тебе до
ты любишь то что ты умеешь вот здесь
хобби
то что кому-то это нужно работа это
благотворительность вот дела это более
простой вариант дики гая дальнейшем вы
увидите для чего это нужно сейчас дальше
пойдем мысли просто мысли у планирования
не стал структурировать не стал там
систематизирует и так далее так далее
даю вам общую картинку потом мы разберем
счастье это лучше измерителя успеха
вот это очень важно понимать еще и штейн
говорил не стремитесь быть успешными а
стремитесь к тому что ваша жизнь имела
смысл
вот это очень важно не стремитесь быть
успешным и стремитесь к тому чтобы ваша
жизнь имела смысл
поэтому если вы счастливый человек то вы
успешный человек не важно сколько у вас
денег не важно кем вы работать не важно
какая профессия и так далее так далее
это просто мы в современном мире
неправильно оцениваем вообще развитие
человечества и все страны друг другу
мериться ростом ввп
ну что такое ввп ввп на самом деле если
увеличивают у нас вся экология
закончится это все наше небо будет дыму
там все полезные ископаемые будут
выкопаны там все переплавлена все
переделано куча мусорке вот-вот что-то к
ввп ввп
она на самом деле противоречит со
счастьем человечество она хорошо когда
бедные
начинают получать доступ каким-то благом
ну а дальше вы потока вредит если оно не
основано там на новых технологиях
зеленых и так далее далее дальше успех
определяется не знаниями не образованием
а действиями
для того что для того чтобы правильно
действовать нужно правильно планирование
и вот смотрите в чем проблема ученых чем
проблема людей образованных вы заметили
что все успешные люди как правило
бросили свои университеты возьмем билл
гейтс вела mask стив джобс цукерберг они
все бросили в университеты вы наверное
заметили что ваши со классники которыми
вместе с вами учились отличники как
правило ничего не добились от двоечники
и хулиганов жизни чего-то добились
так вот почему это происходит я для себя
вот размышлял и пришел к такой формула
дело в том что чем больше у человека
знаний чем больше у человека информации
и чем умнее он тем больше у него выбор
вариантов действий
чем больше выбор вариантов действий тем
труднее принять решение какого действо
делать соответственно умного человека
всегда сомнения это дураки только не
имеет сомнений умный человек сомневается
всегда но есть проблема что достичь
успеха такая существует пропасть и здесь
мостик который называется действие нету
действия нет успеха не важно насколько
ты умен успех возможен только тогда как
выбрал направление действуешь и не
сомневаешься ты идешь все те уже пофиг
ты принял решение пофиг другие
альтернативы и так далее умный человек
думай так я сейчас буду делать вот это
блин а можно вот так поступить блин а
можно было бы так и в результате он хоть
вот это делает но он делает неуверенно а
для того чтобы успеха добиться ты должен
быть уверен как слон просто вот сейчас
много семинаров
по миру и очень популярно там роббинс
тони роббинс еще кто-то вами так далее
они что говорят о как мантру вы должны в
себя верить вы должны быть уверены вы
должны быть там цели как будто вы уже
достигли и так далее и так далее это
говорит только об одном надо быть очень
уверенным
как решили решить делему если вы умный
человек это что приговор теперь я не
буду успешным нет как я сказал 100
дураков действует очень уверенно из них
20 становятся успешными 80 проваливается
умные люди должны 10 таким образом они
должны выбрать способ планирования
такой который исключает сомнение и потом
действовать как дураки ну ты не меньшую
выбрал запланировал и дальше как как
верблюд или как слон идешь вперед и все
сомнения там уже вступает правило так
боишься не делай делаешь не бойся вот
там такой правил дальше если хотите
узнать о вашем прошлом посмотрите на
текущую ситуацию вот если вы хотите
узнать насколько вы были эффективны в
прошлом или успешны посмотрите кто вы
сейчас есть
а если вы хотите узнать о вашем будущем
посмотрите на ваши текущие действия
дальше дело не и дел не доставляющих вам
удовольствие снижает вашу эффективность
это доказано многими исследованиями
исследованиями психологами разными
учеными
но я без не знаю если я делаю в течение
дня там условно 15 дел которым не
приносит удовольствие то в течение могу
сделать максимум три дела который мне не
приносит удовольствие вот все мне все
противиться все не хочется для
эффективности нужна ясность цели а для
ясности цели нужна визуализация вот это
очень-очень сильно и правила для
эффективности нужно ясно целей а для
ясности целей нужна визуализация мы
дальнейшем в дальнейшем разберем что это
такое правильно подобрать цель а потом
отбросить все ненужное
вот уж я и говорил правильно подбирайте
центр
все выкидывать и дальше не сомневайтесь
человеческую занятость нельзя
рассматривать как стакан с водой вот
многие когда делают через систему
планирования ту-ду-ду-ду лист или что
сделать список посмотрим на список дела
и говорит твоя не могу я занят и многие
люди это воспринимают как стакан с водой
который полный но чем отличие к 1
планированием человечку заяц нельзя
рассматривать как стакан с водой это
скорее труба если у вас есть огромный
список дел и вы не успеваете то значит
ваша труба забилось у вас очень низкая
пропускная способность имеет потока либо
у вас проблемы с фильтрами это как
обычно физики вот почему еще
доказательства
отличие времени от жесткого диска или
стакана в том что его нельзя купить
если бы список дел был как стакан с
водой ну мы могли бы купить второй
стакан с водой и перегрузите вы уже не
так заняты
но это на самом деле же не так поэтому
вы должны понимать что ваши дела и ваши
действия и то больше как труба они
емкость потому что любую емкость можно
купить ваша пропускная способность равна
количество законченных дел
деленное на время если вы не важно
сколько дел у вас запланирована неважно
сколько делал вы рассматриваете сколько
дел в день вы заканчиваете делите на
один день 1 рабочий день
вот ваша пропускная способность три дела
в день или 5 дел день абсолютно никого в
этом мире не волнуют сколькими делами вы
занимались людей волнуют только сколько
дел вы закончили
вот это очень важно вот отличие
компоненты обычной системы основаны на
принципе
списка дел но я уже предварительно
сказал вкратце список дел фокусируюсь на
том что делать а комбан система на том
что будет что сделать вкратце им нужно
не работу делать а создавать результат
дальше
список дел стать есть статичен академ
планирование динамично дальше список дел
подавляет академ планировали мотивирует
и вдохновляет
вы дальше увидите что когда у вас вот
такой список дел вы не даже к нему
приступить боитесь он вас демотивирует
у вас подавляет и вот эта прокрастинация
идет отсюда потому что вы не знаете ска
глубоко начать это как вы зашли в бар
дачную пункту и надо наводить порядок и
вы не знаете какого боку начать и для
вас блины все время откладываете и
откладываете и откладываете вот-вот все
откладываете список дел мне показывает
проблему
acadian планерный выявляет проблему
проблему в вашем поведении проблему
ваших целях планирования и так далее то
есть самого системам планируем вам
помогает выявлять ваши проблемы и
совершенствовать или кайден это процесс
непрерывного постоянного совершенствами
основной принцип к 1 планирование это
создание потока что такой поток я покажу
потом кота когда жидкость условно
равномерно течет трубе она же
представьте в трубе да наш нирвана течет
она течет равномерно вот это поток когда
вы нужно дела выстроить таким образом
чтобы они вот такая жидкость рубите клей
ровно равномерно постоянно без нагрузок
и так далее принцип гибкость системы
планирования проблема большинства систем
планируем в том что я занимался кучу
разных систем планирует либо не слишком
подробны и ты вынужден планировать до
часа до минуты а потом пушки нечаянно
или срочно что-то случилось и все к
чертям летит соответственно отсюда
правило чем подробнее систем
планирования тем она более жесткое и
менее гибкая соответственно 12 таких
сбоя
а вам даты дела надо перекидывает на
следующие дни и так далее бросайте
поэтому больше шансов чем более подробно
системы планирования тем она менее
гибкая и тем больше шансов что вы и бра
дальше поэтому гибкая система очень
важно использование всех органов чувств
зрение мышцы тактильные ощущения я
дальше покажу тоже как это работает дело
сможешь когда мы планируем в списке дел
мы просто видим глазами в козин системе
там нужно руками работать я покажу
ясность формулировок чтобы написать свои
мысли на бумаге нужно будет сначала
осознать и правильно сформулировать
проблема в том что у многих из нас
списке дел находится в голове
если вы заметили наверное в голове еще
там есть это такой суп солянка в которой
еще эмоции есть там злость усталость
голод и они все навешиваются и в
результате вы не осознаете что вам
вообще нужно поэтому ясно из
формулировок дает эта система планируя к
1 планет видимость динамики процессов то
есть вы должны видеть динамику и
простатой и
интуитивность вот я на этом пока
остановлюсь со слайдами потому что иначе
это превратится в теоретическую часть я
хочу вам показать продемонстрировать
свойства потока у час мы проведем
эксперимент насколько что дает поток все
я литров воды
только 12 секунд 54
вся четыре сотых 12 ну может снять 13
секунд выливалась бутылка петрова да как
нам ускорить выливание бутылки нужно
закрутить воронку да смотрите воронка
сколько
6 секунда 6 секунд за шесть секунд вы
или бутылку 12 или 13 секунд
обычный способ 6 секунд это через
воронку и три секунды через трубочку при
условии что трубочка туда подают воздух
это я вам просто показываю свойства
потока поток может ускорить все ваши
дела в разы и на самом деле основной
прием казино это построение потока
создания ценности на любом предприятии
когда мы приходим мы что он начинает
бьет мы начинаем выравнивать и
выстраивать поток чтобы все дела шли
равномерно это основа основной
инструмент козин поэтому поток на самом
деле очень важно как вообще
перейти к практической части основной
принцип кайдзен кальцием планирует
заключается в том чтобы все что у вас в
голове есть все что в голове есть мысли
ваши мысли
тревоги мечты
и прочее перевести на бумагу то есть вы
чего делаете вы берете вот такие
листочки такие листочки и просто в любом
порядке здесь его хорошо не надо ничего
за мрачно просто любом порядке купить
автомобиль прочитать такую-то книжку
сходить на концерт там в какой-нибудь
там ну вот к фарму кадык выучить
иностранный язык
что угодно вопрос а вот что угодно
берете и начинайте
начинается стали пить до тех пор это
делать пока у вас в голове вообще
пустота не наступит вот делаете до тех
пор все ваши желания все ваши мечты все
ваши цели все что вам нужно сделать вот
все
основная цель выгрузить вашу голову это
номер один задача чтобы дело в том что
человек беспокоится ровно тогда вот
ученые выяснили и психологи что самое
страшно беспокойство у людей вызывает
незаконченные дела это доказанный факт
незаконченные дела не дают вам спать
потому что вы спите перри заспауним
выдумать блин вот этому еще сделать вот
это надо не забыть вот это надо и так
далее поэтому очень важно вот это второе
второй фактор бессонницей мы когда за
спать в начинает мечтать
погублен вот это была бы вот это сделать
блуа если бы у меня вот это было и
kelpaso капец
это второй третий фактор это
тревоги четвертый фактор это то что вам
кто-то сказал что-то сделать его дедлайн
горит ну короче все вот просто вот сюда
гру грузите
это номер один задачу который вам нужно
сделать дело в том что принцип правила
системы к 1 планирует заключалась в том
что каждая мысль и дать одну карточку
каждая мысль дать одну карточку а уже
вторая часть каждой карточке свое место
но основная задача первое опустошить
вашу голову
дело в том что в чем еще секрет вот
этого метода дело в том что когда вы
начинаете какую-то мысль
свою пытаться сформулировать на бумаге
у вас часто приходят 50 процентов уже
приходит решение как проблему решить или
как это сделать потому что неосознанные
вещи вот есть правило
то что вы не видите вы никогда не
осуществить то что вы не видите вы не
контролируете
обязательно до видеть давайте поправим
то немцы не должно быть мыслей
оттенки сомнений и прочей вне карточки
каждой мысли хотелки сомнению и так
далее свою карточку каждая карточка на
своем месте я бы дальше покажу где даже
сокращайте размер задачи
ешьте слона маленькими кусочками или
пельмешками задачи должны быть
измеримыми момент окончании задачи
должен быть предельно ясным по каждому
момент мы пройдемся то что вы не видите
никогда не осуществите вот это запомните
то что у вас есть в голове но нету на
бумаге вы никогда не осуществить это как
отче наш запомните почему я вам говорю
это тоже исследование потому что когда
вы будете в каждодневной рутиной
заниматься вас все время будто ваш
ежедневник то начальник то еще за
дергают вот эти мысли которые у вас в
голове была цель чего-то сделать она
придет перед сном когда уже более-менее
освободиться
блин опять я не сделал хотел то что
хотел потому что в течение дня вас
атакуют ваши враги
куча ваших врагов это одним отеля
отжирать или времени звонки фейсбук там
еще о чем-то и выбраться этого никогда
не добьетесь того что и поэтому то что
вы не видите никогда не осуществите
то что вы не видите то вы не
контролируете последовательность должна
быть сначала стирка потом глажка вот
согласитесь очень важно сначала стелька
потом глажка они наоборот сначала глажка
потом все это в делах тоже очень важно
дальше одно дело в единицу времени много
задачах это миф максимально ограничите
нагрузку в разделе в процессе увеличивая
количество совершенных задач и
выравниваем нагрузки вот не должно быть
мыслей хотелки сомнений карточки сейчас
мы вот это проходим вот вы все мысли еще
раз по терку
выгружать а на карточку желательно
первое время завести дома вот такую
доску если не доску то там доску на
котором можно этим иголочками
ну что-то такое поверьте мне это реально
стоит того если вы один раз научись это
всю жизнь нас будет спасать потом вы
можете это делать компьютере в айфоне и
неважно но вот это один раз это
упражнение надо проделать и это чего
хорошо здесь не надо никакой тренеры вы
сами поймёте это теперь после этого
процесса это процесс называется
материализация мыслей вы перенесли на
бумагу
это процесс где вы начинаете чувствовать
свои мысли руками это не какие-то
аморфные вещи и до того как этом если
появится вы еще пальцами и рукой будете
писать а до того как писать вы должны
свою мысль проживать и как то
сформулировать и должны тоже не просто
вот недаром говорят что когда у вас вот
немецкая армия хорошие если у вас есть
какая-то жалобно
только письменном форму принимает жалобы
нужно не принимать потому что эмоции
захлестывают и он не может высказать он
просто не может сказать письменной форме
что письменной форме он должен остыть
он должен написать и самое интересное у
нас своих компаниях тоже применяют когда
вы требуете от сотрудников жалобу в
письменной форме очень часто они не
возвращаются потому что во время
формулировки свои жалобы они поняли что
в эфир оно того не стоит
во-вторых они сами решили нашли решение
и в третьих вообще это даже не проблем
оказывается вот как бы такую поэтому вот
это написание
это тоже сам процесс поэтому вы не
осязаемы и аморфные мысли переводите в
осязаемые конкретные бумажки все вот это
называется материализация мыслей и
делайте это до тех пор пока у вас в
голове не будет пусто вот тест такой
простили ты минут 15 смотрит на нас
песик не думайте так что бы мне еще
сделает обамы вот это раз а есть а вот
а есть посмотрели всю есть все после
этого
поверьте мне вам придет определенное
спокойствие насыщению вас придут 2 прим
если всего лишь потом еще одна дверь
потом 2 3 1 2 и вот так они будут
приходить в течение года вот эти будет
70 процентов все ваши мысли остальные
тридцать течении года вам будет
приходить но я вам покажу как с ними
работать
вот смотрите первое самое важное если вы
вот это сделали вы уже очень много
добились очень простая работа очень
понятная второй процесс
вот эти бумажки теперь вы должны
разделить на хочу и должен вы просто
берете заморозки над берете печься хочу
хочу должен
так это я хочу это я должен потому что
мне это сказал это мне должен это вот
этот сказал это я должен потому что там
еще что то вот это еще что то а вот это
я хочу все очень просто вы берете то что
вы игроки дали делается на хочу должен
вот этот вот эта вещь она практически
роль как такую не имеет ни меня не имеет
вы в каждодневной работе вы каждый день
это не будь вы когда стартуйте чтобы
привести в порядок это первичный фильтр
первичный фильтр для того чтобы понять
вообще вы живете своей жизнью или вы
марионетка в чужих руках по этой
диаграмме сразу видно что практически
вы выполняете чужую волю все время вы
выполняете чужие хочу смотрите вот это
ваша должен это всегда чей-то хочу
вы должны понимать если вы четко должны
сделать значит потому что начальник
чего-то хочет если вы что-то должны
сделать потому что ваш супруг или
супруга чего-то хочет еще что то вы
должны сделать потому что ваши дети
этого хотят то есть должен хочу они
всегда
если вы это ставить в должен знать вы
выполняете чужой я хочу а наша же цель
сегодняшнего мастер-класса научить вас
тому чтобы делать ваши хочу вот это в
каждодневной работе вам не понадобится
это вот моменте когда вывод выгружайте
всю массу для анализа чтобы вы поимели
картинку как вообще у вас обстоят дела
все вот это сделали вот от первичное
разделение вот это первичное разделение
оценили это называется первичное
разделение или оценка оценка она в
дальнейшем вам не понадобится
как вы внедрить эту систему она даже не
понадобится почему это делается сейчас
на этом уровне потому что у вас это
наследство до системы планирования на к
вам пришло да и вы должны ценить как вы
вот помните правило сегодня ситуация
отражает ваши прошлые действия
вот только для оценки в дальнейшем когда
вы будете планирует у вас не будут уже
такого то есть вы уже в дела будете
выбирать через призму сразу
братец они братца делать не делать и
педаль первично разделяем наверно
правильно назвать оценка или имя
инвентаризация дальше наступает
достаточно сложный момент вот здесь
фильтр нужно вам определить миссию
который отвечает на вопрос кто я и для
чего я живу вот это самый главный вопрос
любого человека и не ответив на него вы
никогда не построить эффективную систему
планирования
это как примерно есть я вам скажу куда
вы едете или куда идете и вы скажете не
знаю я три часа буду идти куда вы придет
никогда не придут или вам скажу
вообще ты кто ты куда идёшь не знаю ну
как ты можешь это вот и жизнь до без ты
сам не знаешь куда ты идешь надо
принципиально ответить иначе вы будете
заниматься всем то что вот это модно вот
этим на искал если вы не ответить на
вопрос миссии вы всегда будет заниматься
тем что должны потому что если у вас нет
своего хочу вы всегда будете выполнять
чужой я хочу это правило то что природа
не терпит пустоты
вы должны понимать вода зарубите себе на
носу если вы не сформулировали свое хочу
то вы всегда будете выполнять чужое хочу
соответственно вся ваша жизнь будет
состоять из должен должен должен должен
должен должен соответственно это только
стресс это ругань и такой войне какой
части в жизни может сразить я привел
здесь как свою миссию как пример вот у
меня миссия вот такая прожить счастливую
жизнь первое с пользой для общества и
окружающей среды это на вопрос для чего
я живу на вопрос кто я я отвечаю я тот
живет счастливой жизни с пользой для
общества и окружающей среды вот эта
миссия
теперь как она влияет на систему
планирования как я вот эта беру потом и
делаю вот такой 3 график я делю вот
такой град и делаю и говорю это делает
меня счастливее или нет это полезно
обществе нет это понятно окружаешь среде
нет я беру вот эти вещи так вот это
нужно общество вот это нужно обществу
вот это делает меня счастливее вот это
делает не счастливее
вот это делает меня счастливее а вот это
ни туда ни сюда этот график можно уже
стирать это не график это фильтр это
знаете вот чтобы четко еще представляет
что такое вот представьте вот вы у вас
жидкость какая-то до
накопилось огромное чем 100 литров
жидкости нужно его порядок привести вы
чё делать вот этот первый фильтр во
первых вот этот раз удар ствола здесь
жидкость 100 литров вы вылили сначала
бак все выделить что-то там чисто было
выглядеть
потом этот ставите фильтр хочу должен и
на две ёмкости разбивайте хочу должен
разгромить
потом сайте три емкости это делает меня
счастливее
это полезно обществу это полезно
кружочками
разливайте в три емкости развязав осадок
остался вот этот непонятный он недели
окружающей среде пользы нету ни обществу
не меня 6 не идет чего с ним делать вот
здесь есть отдельный баг который это не
мои мысли и желания и надо выбрасывать
мусорку но до того как выбросить мусорку
вы должны взять от листок вот чем
хороший команд система планирования
каждой мысли у вас
машка вы ее ощупайте вы ее чувствуете вы
ее видите и вы работаете в вас мозги не
работает практически вывод с бумажками
работ вы чувствуете думать так почему
она ко мне пришла и там и купить
спорткар там такой-то
что я круто вожу машину нет что я люблю
водить машину ну особо не чего скорость
люблю
то нет ну потому что тот кент купил
спортивную машину и этот купил ну и я
чтобы свое эго потешить
. я тоже куплю и понимать этот чужие
мечты или это может быть мода навязанная
вам либо чья-то командой чего-то хочу
которую не попадает ваш фильтр и
выговорить так этот человек мной
манипулируют манипулятор так можете
вычислить это человек но и манипулируют
он не хочет чтобы я был счастливее он не
хочет него пользовавшийся не обществе
окружают себе лично хочет он просто мной
манипулируют и после анализа
выкидываете в корзину вот вы кинули в
корзину вот эта система фильтров
повторюсь она не нужно будет вам кайна
каждодневное планирование это делать со
всего один раз сейчас когда вы будете
чистить свою голову чтобы все что в
голове перевести на бумагу и дальше
создать вот этот поток вот фильтр
вот фильтр выбрать или ненужное когда мы
эти все мысли посмотрели дело в том что
занята человека еще чем определяется вот
представьте трубу с жидкостью если она
не справляется почему она может не
справляться 1 а потому что слишком много
с этой стороны дел но это не проблема
второе потому что у этой трубы мету
обводной трубы дополнительной вот эта
обводная труба это называется
делегирование вы часть своей работы свою
хочу можете кому-то сделать чем-то
должен попросить там и так далее так
далее или подчиненную ему передать или
это ободная труда turbo который помогает
достигать ваши цели у вас своя труба и
еще вы можете трубу подчиненного
испортить ему кинуть дела и он выполнит
для вас и третье что ограничь пункте мы
сказали дела должны как жидкость трубе
третье что ограничивает вашу
производительность
это когда отсутствие фильтр или они
засорились так вот благодаря этим
фильтром мы из списка дел выкидываем вот
эти вещи все что модно все что вам
навязали
это здесь одна бумажка а там может
оказаться 20 30 процентов может вы
выкидываете вы поняли да вот это список
дел у вас сразу сократится автоматом
просто пройдя эту стадию он сократится
вы перестанете делать чужое хочу которой
они не вас не делать счастливее не
общество не природе не полезно вот этот
фильтр выполняет функцию отсева мусора
но мусор просто так нельзя выкидывать
его надо анализировать для того что в
будущем не попадаться на одно и то же
грабли не наступать и будущем уже у вас
в голове будет строим этот фильтр когда
вам дают что-то просят делать и
результат быстро думать так это меня
сделать из него нет польза есть обществе
окружены из разграждения soria не я пас
все вы уже в голове у вас это стоит
фильтр но этот фильтр надо пройти через
бумагу не доску для того чтобы оно
закрепилось вашей памяти до автоматизма
вы должны 11 работ сами
потому что только появится другой
человек вы чуть-чуть начнете на него
работать на публику а смысл ты сам себя
вот вечером или когда ты остаешься на 11
даже сделал все законно даже сделал все
правильно когда ты оставишь на 11 тыс
внутри все серьезно и что чуть-чуть этом
косичка 1 ну чуть-чуть я покрою прошел с
вами есть хорошее правило избегая
сомнительного вот вы должны кстати
взять это за правило избегайте
сомнительного должно быть все четко и
ясно в к-1 вообще не любит сомнительно
никаких серых зон
все должны быть предельно ясно у вас
эмоции чисто эмоции
а дела чисто дела и когда у вас
происходит что-то в голове вы знаете
подождите его вот у меня все дела на
бумаге
сразу видно то есть любые такие вопросы
это добро или зло это полезно не полезно
вы через сердце пропускайте и сто
процентов у вас будет ответ но
единственное условие только один на один
и потому что сами собой вы навряд ли
будет себя обманывать ну тебя обманывать
тогда вообще лучше не заниматься этим
если это тебя делать счастливее если ты
это знаешь что тебя делать счастливее
понятно есть же какие вещи которые когда
ты говоришь условно в моей миссии там
использовать для общества значит и ты не
можешь быть счастливой там убив кого-то
там или что-то наградив кому-то ну то
есть с той стороны является
ограничительным закон с той стороны и
твоя мораль то есть если брать такую
этот вот дорога там условно к счастью
здесь стоит закон его переступишь явно
ты будешь несчастливым потом еще одни
барьер стоит мораль
мораль и вот и переступишь понятно ты
закон не нарушишь но ты счастлива и не
будешь потому что ты пошла против своей
морали а вот это место вот да да вот
этой стены
никого и ничего собачье дело это твое
будь счастлива по этому какие вопросы не
надо оглядываться не надо смотреть не
надо это если вы не нарушаете закон если
вы 10 в рамках морали беспокойтесь
только о своем счастье мне молодые
предпринимать очень много вопросы и
говорит мой выигрыш вот вы
планировали систем планирую используя
для чего как можно больше дел сделать
игру глупость моя система планируем на
правильно только на то как можно больше
мне освободить времени нет как можно
сделать больше дел а как можно больше
освободить мне времени
вот поймите огромную разницу если у вас
цель сделать как можно больше дел вы
загонять себя в стресс потому что дело
никогда не кончаются вы еще больше еще
больше еще больший путь потом срыв потом
депрессия потом вообще нахрен это все
нужное перессориться со всеми поэтому
систему планирования нельзя использовать
для того чтобы выполнить много дел
система планирования
используется для того чтобы выполнять
только те дела которые делают вас либо
счастливым либо пользу приносит обществу
либо пригласить пользу окружающей среде
все остальные отдыхайте и у вас
высвобождается куча времени и в эту кучу
времени вы можете запланировать пойти
потанцевать сыграть ворлд оф танк еще
что-то сделать поваляться в постели и
вообще никого не видит норман воля на
самом деле это временный механизм эта
пружинка есть механизм гипер компенсации
если вы голодайте два-три дня потом вы
так а базируйте если вы резко скинули
вес там 5 килограмм то вы обязательно
наберете семь килограммов пока не
остановится то есть вы никогда вот так
не будет 5 когда он сбросил потому 1 5
килограмм в
вернул нет вы вернете 7 это механизм
гепаргин компенсации кость если вы
где-то сломали то место где заросло
никогда не ломается ломается в другом
месте потому что там механизм бибер
компенсации пришлось делать так что там
сильнее
запасом все делается поэтому здесь это
не работает воля не работает но воля
механизм воли он как ключей работает
механизм более чем питается он питается
энергией
более той же энергия воля питается
энергией так вот если вы и так себя в
угол загнали кучин их дел
и вот батарейка на исходе вы включаете
болью не включаете закончится плохо а
если вы повалялись
два-три дня блин энергии в баланду ты
девать некуда вы просто жаждете что то
сотворить
и вы делать любимое дело но надо пройти
кучу там там какие-то усилия делать для
вас это не будет усилим вы просто
пролететь и это все потому что у вас
избыток энергии который питает волю
соответственно воля автоматом появится
вот я бы так сказал воля без энергии
равно нулю энергия создает волю а
энергия приходит только тогда когда вы
живете счастливой жизнью в которой есть
периоды
безделья любым любимым делом короче чем
больше вы свою жизнь наполняйте любимыми
делами счастливыми которые тот же не
кидай тем больше вы получать энергию вот
мне еще вопросы дают молодые ребята
часто говорят вот как вы успеваете там
совсем встречаться откуда силы
но я секрет вам рассказал что я
бездельничаю иногда фигнёй занимается
это раз второй момент дело в том что
когда вы встречаетесь с интересными
людьми либо вы каждые делаете проекты
которые на шаг приближает вас к вашей
мечте вы вместо того чтобы
силы терять вы приобретаете силы и вы
начинаете работать еще больше пункте я
привел правило если вы выполняете
работа которые не пример с вам
удовольствие ваша эффективность падает и
наоборот если выполняет работу который
придется вам удовольствие и фиксировать
вас возрастает благодаря этой системе
планирования coating system планируем у
вас возникает такое ощущение вот заказал
тем какую-то машину или женщина там
какую сумму платье неважно что заказали
но тот что нельзя сразу купить и вот вы
ждете в предвкушении что вот вот вот она
придет вот заказ мой придет вот мой
заказ придет вот я уже заказ делала
оплатила примерку прошла там вот вот так
of придет вот это то состояние в котором
я живу
благодаря этой системе планирования у
меня есть мечты мои цели и каждый день
когда я делаю я знаю что на шаг
приближаю и у меня как у охотничьи
собаки азарт я знаю вот сейчас за
поворотом вот эта мечта осуществится за
этим поворотом вот это моя хотелка
выполнить и каждый день азарт каждый
день азарт каждый день удовольствия и
соответственно силы
когда ты выполняешь свое хочу они
чего-то хочу
естественно будет силой поэтому вот это
фильтр очень важен пойдем дальше вот мы
сделали фильтрации через миссию миссию
смело можете мог заимствовать мою миссию
то миссия может быть разная главное себе
ответьте на вопрос
вот кто я и это будет ваша истинная они
те роли социальные которые вам общество
навязала
и который вы обязаны выполнять дело в
том что когда общество навязывает там
какие-то роли
без много психологических книг по этому
поводу еще она загоняет вас в рамки
должен у каждой роли
прописан вот такой список должен и
общество манипулирует членами общества
таким образом как ты такой то в этом не
проблема что с детства когда мы растем
мы нам во первых общество навязывает а
во-вторых мы сами себе говорим я такой
то и мы одеваем на себя этот футляр а
этот футляр состоит только из слов
должен если ты это тот и должен делать
вот это вот это вот это а если ты вот
это ты должен делать вот это вот это
соответственно devoured и начинаем
играть эту роль поэтому миссия это то
что кто вы есть это единственная роль
которую вы в этой жизнь должна выполнять
если хотите быть счастливым
есть еще такое правило человек никогда
не будешь счастлив если будет играть
чужую роль как сегодня сказали
никогда не сможешь стать добиться чужого
часть вот ради счастье детей не когда
дети вырастут блюд на родителей
нельзя жить ради детей дело в том что
когда ты выстроил миссию и живешь ради
себя и ты счастлив дети учатся на не на
словах а на примерах поэтому я вам ещё
раз подчёркиваю любая роль которую вы на
себя одевайте это попытка играть ту роль
который вам навязали
и вы в нее никогда не будете супер
профессионалами вы всегда будете в
косяке
и вот только единственная роль которую
вы должны в этой жизни
мясе определить и в нее играть еще есть
такое правило
говорится либо ты в этой жизни играешь
либо тобой играют когда вы применяют
любую социальную роль им это вами играют
когда вы определили свою миссию и
внедрить эту систему планирование это вы
начинаете играть свою партию
вот мы дошли до фильтров после фильтров
дальше ведем мы работаем теперь с этим
блоком с этим блоком дальше у нас идет
вот так вот это вот этот блок здесь
просто повтор в этот лук дальше идет
фильтр из пяти направлений личностное
развитие семья бизнес дело общественного
хобби
также деле
произвольно вот личностное развитие
семья бизнес общество
это тоже фильтр для чего он делается для
того чтобы посмотреть вообще структуру
ваших всех хотелок и мысли в голове вы
берете и говорите так это связано
прочтение
там книге она кореньями вот это
личностное развитие вот ту связи там
куда-то в дубай это с семьей еду так вот
этот цели за работу с топотом миллионов
долларов это бизнес вот это купить джип
обе и вот это например еще бизнес все
раскидали
так как у вас будет очень много таких
листочков вывод так раскидывайте для
чего это делается первое для того чтобы
увидеть структуру вы практически сейчас
структуру ваших мыслей в мозгу
видеть его мозгу вы так не увидеть а
когда на бумаге вают и вы поймёте куда у
вас больше клонит чего вы больше всего
хотите достичь или куда вас тянет к
личностному развитию и так далее так
далее это первая цель вторая самая
важная цель это чтобы не упустить ни
один из этих 5 вещей не одно дело в том
что если вы что-то упустить и есть такая
звезда когда вы должны всесторонне вот
эти вещи делать иначе вас не будь
счастливой жизни тоже каждый человек
рисует профиль вот значит личностное
развитие вот так бизнес вот так это вот
так потом
это вот так может быть это вот так ну
вот моя картинка вот такая там некоторые
пишут что в каждой это у человека разные
роли запутайтесь не надо вам никакой
роли ваша роль вот и ваша цель миссия
для чего вы пришли в эту жизнь под что
такое счастье или возьмем один из
главных компонентов счастья эта свобода
у каждой свобода и так понятно нет если
разложить свобода состоит из трех свобод
это физическая свобода когда вы не за
дни в заключение а можете передвигаться
там и так далее это юридическая свобода
вы же не можешь сейчас взять и поехать в
сша вам нужно визу пол
а если у вас есть виза тогда у вас есть
юридическая свобода поехать сша
если вы в заключении вы не можете даже
до аэропорта доехать и третье финансовая
свобода у вас есть свобода у вас есть
виза а денег нет это финансовая свобода
так вот счастья достигается когда у тебя
расширяется финансовая свобода а
финансовая свобода достигается за счет
бизнеса за счет
бизнес достигается за счет личностного
развития они все друг другом связаны
поэтому вот эти пять я их отдельно
выделил с точки зрения роли вы должны
держать только одну роль вот она вот эту
вот а степень как вы в этой звезде для
того что вот например
семья да кто-то семье очень много
это домосед кто-то счастлив когда семье
вот столько внимание уделяет вы
счастливы на этом уровне
кто-то личностное развитие вообще вот
так занимается личностным развитием а
бизнесом вообще вот так занимается кто
то очень много внимания уделяет хобби
вот говорят есть даже историю бросил
работу начал заниматься любимым делом
вот удар в это хобби
но хобби без бизнеса он долго не протяну
хоть там дайверам работает на каком-то
пляже на мальдивах
если он за это деньги не собирает
достаточно для того чтобы обеспечить
свою свободу экономическую он долго
дайвера не против и второй момент вот
этих ролей есть два качества одно вы
когда вам навязывают ты хороший отец
веди себя как хороший отец второе когда
ты сам гараж я хороший отец но это не
значит что я должен вот это делать вот
это делаю достаточно мое понимание
хорошего завод все поэтому
разбиватель на такой фильтр этот фильтр
я
вторая задача этого фильтра заключается
в том чтобы ничего не упустить видите у
меня в обществе из пустоты это ничего
страшного но я досидела вывод я должен
что-то все-таки для общества сделать
часто человек упускает просто говорят с
глаз долой из сердца вон до из глаз вот
принцип визуализации вы просто упустили
что надо заниматься общественно делами
но там внутри то вы знаете что надо
заниматься в числе делами и вот вы
направлять эти раз смотрите у вас от это
столбик пустой вы думаете блин а у вас
потребность я сделать пел в том что у
каждого человека есть потребность
приносить пользу обществу у каждого
это как метод социализации метод еще
самореализации вот есть такая пирамида
маслоу и ты должен чтоб чувствует себя
счастливым ты должен что-то давать
отдавать ну вы можете там одни сетей там
детский сад там чего не будет или в
детдом сходить в сторожке помочь по
соседству это все пользу общества дерево
посадить хороший пример и вот вы сидите
думаете я в принципе молодец все хорошо
дел но надо мне чего-то все-таки сделать
и дел тушь когда вот этот столбец вы
можете себя не заставлять не вообще
никогда тебе не заставляйте вы просто
сами вас внутри что-то проститься из
каждый блин надо что-то сделать привод
просто начать то дерево позади тебя
этому помочь или сходить там бабушкам
что-то сделать и вы раз и суда ставите
листок это первый звонок и первый сигнал
вы сами начали формировать свою повестку
дня то есть это никто вам не сказал
никто вам не навязал никто вам не
манипулировал это первая ваша задача
которую вы сами осознали и посчитали
нужным и ее внедрили в план только вы
написали на бумажке все она вошла ваш
план уже сейчас я дальше покажу как то
есть заметьте появилась новая задача
посади дерево да она теперь не проходит
вот эти фильтры заново через миссию
через должен хочу вы уже автоматом
голове держите вы видите что блин я хочу
что-то сделать вы уже знаете что вот вы
в этом хоть и он сюда прилепили это к
тому что не пугались вот это фильтр
нужен всего один раз вот разбили
вот этот фильтр вам нужно применять
каждый год конец года конец года и вы
опять раскладываете потому что каждый
день или каждый год приносит новые дела
а еще в этот фильтр чего дает этот
фильтр дает ощущение вам полноты жизни
что вы делаете все правильно вы ничего
не упустили
что нету секторов которые вы упустили
вы знаете что ваша система планирования
полная всеобъемлющее
вот это ощущение очень важно это убивает
все ваши сомнения
вот для этого еще нужно вот этот фильтр
что убит все сомнения иначе вы все время
думаете так что то делать блин
а для себя это делаю вообще админ вот
лично за развитие там забивать книжки
изучении иностранных языков трансы
педали потом расчет делать для да я бегу
я зарабатывая сейчас в общем от меня
позже какая-то не с обществами вот это
как раз вам эту совесть
вашу успокаивает и когда у вас в этот
лес вы смотрите и думаете так я
красавчик я все делаю правильно нету
ничего что я бы забыл и мне
соответственно нету сомнений у меня не
может быть сомнений у меня все и я делаю
для хобби и для общества и для бизнеса
для семьи для себя лично я делаю все
соответственно любая сфера деятельности
суда путешествие семьей суда один
познавательно сюда книжки читать суда
танцы суда там женой в кино ходить сюда
там бизнес дед вот пожалуйста любые
бабки соседки помочь суда дерево
посадить сюда с браконьерами побороться
суда там на парашюте на парашюте
прыгнуть сюда все теперь полный но самое
главное это я повторюсь это фильтр
который успокаивает вашу совесть и
который убивает все ваши сомнения
будущем когда вы начнете реализовывать
свои планы вы уже назад не когда-нибудь
оглянуться и говорить а может я что-то
забыл не забыл ты ничего все есть после
этого мы вот это все надо приземлять и
вот тут у нас на сцене появляется комбан
2018 года это ну предстоящего года 1
этот отрезок которые все эти бла-бла-бла
теории так далее надо на землю
приземлять вы уже делаете вот так очерти
войти
вас на доске должно быть годовое и
месячный канбан здесь нужно сделать но
это вам нужно сделать вы сами это не
кто-то вам в этом вам нужно это выбрать
мне нужно сделать нужно сделать
запланировано сделано в годовом всего
три все суда перевести мусорку ничего не
выбрасывайте потому что вы помните в
мусорку выбросили то что ваша миссия не
соответствует а вот здесь уже все то что
соответствует вашей миссии канбан что
такое канбан карману переводе с
японского карточки вот эти карточка этой
из команд по сути и вот что вы делаете
вы вот эти все
вот после таких фильтров переносе суда
на там фильтр и у вас остается вот это
который восемнадцатом году вы не
сделаете это может быть 19-м году
двадцатом году так как у меня на айфоне
у меня там на 10 лет вперед вот такие
соответственно я вот это то что через
фильтр вот этот прошло вот этот фильтр
он у меня всегда пустой и оттуда все
карточки раскидывать так это реально
сделать восемнадцатом году это реально
сделать девятнадцатом году это ренди
двадцатом году этот двадцать первым это
двадцать третьем их кидаю основная идея
вот эти пять столбцов а у меня должны
быть пустыми
вот это вот так висит не должно быть
должно быть вот этих вот эти столбцы
вот миссии после миссии когда вы сюда
переносите вот смотрите вот отсюда вы
переносите вот это остается пустой вы
это стирайте потом отсюда это в мусорку
проанализировали в мусорку вот это
берете вот она
переносе суда по 5 этим вот это пустая
стирайте после этого у вас вот эти
полные
вы вот это раскидываете по годам к нам
18 19 20 21 и так далее потому что ваши
мечты могут быть длинные трехлетние
пятилетние так далее но все должно быть
так 8 нас 1920 выглядеть должны вот так
и вы просто их кидать сюда нужно сделать
это в каком бы просто вы видите в каком
году что нужно сделать теперь когда вы
раскидали
восемнадцатый год предположим декабрь
месяц 17 сейчас идет вы создаете вот
такую комбо карточку ну давайте января
назовем и вы думаете из этого что
реально сделать в январе так вот это
реально
переносицу да вот это нужно то есть от
ни души я хочу а там учетом не ясуда
переношу
так вот это постараюсь в январе так ну и
так далее здесь могут быть там 50
листочков вы переносите вот это в январе
все кидайте сюда теперь если у вас нету
комбо на например мая месяца на карточке
берете пишите в мае 20
сделать вот это и вставьте в
запланирована чтобы не создавать 12
таких досок в году уже 12 месяцев
выперли сюда в запланируем сюда карточка
вот так вот это сделает в августе
поехать на забронировать там отеле и так
далее да вот это там в 1 сентября в
школу надо вот этого так сделать все
и правом на них пишите все это
запланированный а все что январь
переносе суда на январскую доску начнем
вас становится у вас и всех мыслей
получается вот эти нужно сделать но вы
пока не знаете когда и где вы найдете
будете размышлять
вот эти вы уже дата определены это все
что не январь
все что а вот это все что я говорю вы
перевезти сюда все что января после
этого это нужно но это нужно сделать в
январе а в какой день января и понятно
поэтому какие-то вещи вы знаете сразу
это я делаю на следующий понедельник
некоторые встречи за риски от вас и от
вашего контрагента и вы пишете
процессе внешней стороны исполнителя
например я написал
женеве куда давай встретимся там в
следующий вторник я же не могу себе план
еще поставить потому что он не дал
подтверждение я годовая следующий
вторник в 11 часов в кафе руми он не дал
подтверждение я подвешены
я по в процессе исполнения но мишне на
мейстер на его стороне и я себя не
обвиняю потому что я свою часть работы
сделал вы поняли да все теперь джаныбек
или кто-то там мне прислал емейл этом
рынке там прочитай какой-то проект всю
игру так я сейчас должен вот это сделать
сегодня я должен быть отделка ему слово
длинный я 1 мяч на моей стороне я должен
ответить
у меня вообще каждому только один час
игры вот это надо сегодня сделать вот
это мяч на моей стороны сегодня должна
должен сделать так вот это запланировал
в ту дату который я запланировал все вот
я сегодня должен делать из вот этого
огромного количества листочков
я должен думать сегодня только а вот
этих двух у вас там 50 70 ваше желание
хотелок который вы описали а делать-то
надо вот это заметьте смысл потока в чем
заключается когда я вам показывал три
потока выливаю бутылку во всех трех я
менял что я менял только способ как
увеличить пропускную способность
горлышко
вы поняли на самое критичное место
горлышко так вот пропускная способность
всей бутылке равна пропускной
способности горлышко поэтому чтобы
увеличить пропускную способность
горлышко и и крутил создавая врут вихрь
поэтому я стал трубку чтобы воздух туда
попадал и вода быстрее бадикова так вот
управляете в единицу времени только в
узким местом горлышком а это у вас
сегодня у вас будущего еще нет вчера уже
прошло у вас есть только сегодня
в этом плане хорошего фразу одежды
американских президентов сказал делайте
то что можете с тем что у вас есть
сейчас почему это система планирования
еще лучше других систем потому что это
система планирования учитывает
незавершенных дела сегодня ты эту работу
делал делал делал дошел до какого-то
момента результаты работы отчет сбросил
шефу ты пишешь процессе мяч на ферме
исполнителей потом опять
он тебе ответил говорит так вы все там
что то это вот так действует этот раз ты
сегодня опять же
потом раз какой тебе прислали большой
файл надо прочесть блин ты берешь его
процесса мяча на моей stermy то есть ты
над ним работаешь на он большой поэтому
ты под тоже не сегодня попозже
прочитаешь вот план процессе
и у тебя вот так а потом когда ты сделал
ты переносишь сделано у меня в
личностном развитии возле стоит изучить
арабский язык достаточно большая большая
непонятно какого боку приступить так вы
не факт что я за 2 1018 год его освоив
так что я делаю что такое знание языка
это чтение
нет сначала это алфавит потом счет потом
чтение потом разговор согласно вот мы
основном на 4 уже распилили
после этого помните правило сначала
стирка потом глажка
сначала алфавит потом счет потом чтение
потом разговор я что делаю восемнадцатом
году я пишу я могу освоить алфавит любой
из вас скажет могу я восемнадцатом году
магуа свой счет арабский
любой скажет могу я власть на самом году
могу научиться читать любой скажет могу
а вот разговаривать не понятно согласны
беру карточку арабский язык его и и
уничтожаю
и из нее делаю четыре новых карточки
научиться изучать арабский алфавит
научиться считать по-рабски научиться
читать парадке научиться говорить
по-арабски
первые три я ставлю суда она учится
говорить по-арабски я кидаю на 19 год
понятно да дальше к кражам слона вот
научиться возьмем произвольно там
алфавиту
я беру что я могу из алфавита в январе
сделать выучить 10 букв
пишу выучить 10 2 арабского значит
выучить арабский алфавит
я картошку делю на три карточки выучить
10 букв выучить 20 вторую десятку
выучить перейти взятку я оттуда беру
первую десятку и лажу суда в январе
реально 10 букв алфавита рабского
учителю ли
то есть она система построена таким
образом что вы ничего потерять не можете
то есть у нас система построена таким
вот вы берете слона
порезали на куски доказав ключевскую
лошадь сон порезали на куски и против
каждого куска мяса положили карточку
монах жилет и пишите берут карточку
prestima нас жили вот эту карточку
manolo мортка и вот так вы от лошади
делать и зеркало в виде карточек и когда
вы словом идите прежде чем бросать он
march of каструлю бросили да вы берете
карту и вешаете на доске такой делать
запись в кастрюле
у вас так же здесь будут в холодильнике
в кастрюле выбирайте карточку amarth х
ложки к в кастрюле
варится варится когда
по сварилась выпишет берете в процессе
процессе
кушайте как селе выкинули вам радха
берете карточку таким сделано и потом вы
видите лошадь вы можете по запчастям co2
должна быть вот левая лопатка остаться
то есть эта система такая вы не можете
потерять задачу вообще вы не можете ее
потерять вот это отличие от списков
будут там списка дел и так далее
карточки комбан карточки это зеркало
вашей мысли вот одна мысля помните одна
мысль одна карточка и она потом начинает
дробиться и растекаться по календарям по
датам и так далее так далее и выцелить
сто процентов добьетесь когда вот эти
все карточки пройдут через этот трубу
просто сто процентов шансов нет не
выполнить вот смотрите ладно продолжим
перешли сюда вот в январе сделать и
yanvar уже вместе с более короткий и вы
чё делаете вы начинаете уже пользуется
вашим обычным
ежедневником или
календарем которого в смартфоне уже вот
там вы пользоваться обычным вашим этим
где есть часы
есть даты субботы воскресенья указанные
так далее и там просто смотрите у вас
эта карточка
вот эта система она даёт вам то чтобы вы
не потеряли ваши мечты ваши мысли и так
далее и еще благодаря этому ваша голова
всегда пустая и вы что делает мяч на
стороне исполнителя мяч на моей стороне
вот это можно сделать сегодня потом
когда сделано
суда накопилось вот это месяц прошел
сделано накопилось вот это все вот так
накопилось а это не сделано еще
ну там на плане или вот так не сделано
вы что делает вывод это в конце
последнего месяца берете эти карточки
переносим сделано 18 года а вот эту
переместив комбан февраля
либо там марта неважно можете легко
переносить и что у вас происходит с
каждым месяцем вы видите сколько дел вы
завершили
с каждым месяцем с каждым днем с каждым
годом вы физически ощущаете как ваши
мечты превращаются в вашу реальность и
каждый день каждый год вы видите что вы
живете той жизнью которую сами для себя
именно по тому сценарию которые сами для
себя выбрали
и это дает неимоверная силу неимоверная
эмоциональную это дает вам неимоверно
заряд бодрости и энергии и вы готовы
совершать
единственно что вы при такой системе
планирует планирование хотите это еще
быстрее делать еще быстрее делать чтобы
еще быстрее достигать своих целей но
самое интересное так как вы занимаетесь
любимым делом и то у вас будут
получаться еще легче обязательно
перечитывайте и просто кайфуйте я в этом
году сделал вот это вот это вот это вот
эта проблема других систем планирую
особо нужны списки дел
ты делаешь вычеркивай же и забываешь и
такой что жизнь не зря прожил и самое
интересное что вот эта система
планирования вам даст ощущение контроля
над своей жизнью потому что вы знаете
откуда приходят события откуда приходят
предположим так эта задача этого если
было связано с там шефом а он уже это не
может делать через немытые
это берет уберете карточку выкидывайте
вот было сто мысли и 100 меч стала 99
вот почему эта система гибкая либо вы
он просто волшебно заболел там условно
через два месяца выйти на работу вы сюда
пишите там карточка
выполнение в марте месяце запланирован
все оно не теряется у вас все дальше
любой чего-то извелась появилась новая
вводная
в голове не держите сразу у вас есть
куда
заполнять вы сразу вот этот есть фильтр
проходить не надо вы сразу уже знаете
так это делает меня счастливее
делает а если это меня делать счастливее
и то что связано с моей личностью или
семья или хобби или бизнес уже примерно
представили за дальше после так это в
этом году реальности
реально выпишет на рис . сразу до нужно
сделать уже фильтры не нужные фильтры
нужны чтобы обладать весь ваш бардак
провести через это сито один раз а потом
найтись это уже будут вас голове
установлены
они уже все установленные и когда новая
задача приходит в из raw говорят пройти
через это пропустили раз на
восемнадцатый год поставили все а потом
свободное время есть я рекомендую в час
времени утром всегда посвящать планирую
у меня называется к 1 час и смотрите так
8 а сам буду я поставил а в конкретно в
каком месте была бы самой
реально это сделать ну словно я хочу
поехать дубае дубае погода когда хорошим
учатся весна уже пустил 8 мая хорош в
октябре и пишет в октябре берете билет и
все посмотрели отеле посмотрели всего
нормально всего за год туз подгадали
запланирован все будет вам дубай в
октябре самое лучшее время года вот
понимаете вы система планируем очень
сильно зависит от контекста важно же
эффективная реализация или эффективно
детях когда вы делаете нужное дело в
нужном нужном месте в нужное время в
нужном количестве вот эти все моменты
это называется контекст а те системы
планируя которые через список там и так
далее так далее вот это ганта диаграмма
гантта и так далее вы там запланируем вы
должны делать неважно что у вас в этот
момент энергии нет неважно что у вас в
этот момент силы не
неважно что слякоть на улице дождь не
важно что там еще учета ты систем
планирование учитывают контекст а ещё
очень важный момент вот эту систему я
разбил именно по месяцам
потому что смотрите день слишком
короткие ты мало чувстве его сделать и
задача очень маленьких пельменей когда
ты будешь пельмени трудно представить
что они изд-во надо
и ты раз это ты думаешь блин выучить я
тут делаю или нет а но ты знаешь так как
у тебя были фильтры в да все у тебя
никаких чужих задач не все твою теперь
что-то менять еще результатов нету
реагирует сложно это короткий период
подводить итоги года
блин ты говоришь блинам но поменять на
год уже прошел уже слишком большой
период месяц самый идеальный период
месяц прошел ты вот это сделано в
течение месяца прочитал проанализировал
и уже на следующий день корректирует
свое поведение так надо больше сейчас
общественный давануть
так надо больше по бизнесу
давай ну я лично развитие упустил надо
еще дополнительно две книжки прочитать
давануть
и вы уже вот это начинайте в голове
упражнение диод вот эти так потому что у
вас есть статистика статистика это факт
и это не эмоции это факт и с которыми
споры бесполезно это вот ваши вот эти
все а я вам покажу как решил сделать
сразу определят что это вот это это
очень просто делается на 5 этих делайте
5 цветных присваивайте семье один цвет
хобби другой цвет вот вы сразу делайте
это 7 условно наделенным там личностное
развитие
сделайте там желтым общественный la
делайте например условно красным бизнес
делать и синим хобби делать оранжевым
это вы сами можете как угодно делать
теперь что получается когда вот эта
цветная армия пойдет по вот этой трубе
сразу вы можете сказать сколько вы
общественно делать дело сколько бизнес
дел делать сколько лично развить и
сколько это все сразу видно это и это
факт и это статистика и это ваши мысли и
ваши дела но когда месяца качество вывод
это стираете вывод это не выкидывайте вы
все все все все переносит восемнадцатый
год сделано и вот вот это копится и
каждый раз вы кайфуете когда смотрят
дела her ведь я красавчик
существует еще две вещи которые нужно
планировать
первая задача первая вещь это рутинные
дела который каждый день повторяется
каждый день повторяется повторять
повторять я делаю так беру свой
ежедневник и сразу каждые забиваю там
условно в 6:00 подъем там прогулка с 8
до 9 у меня к 1 час и у каждый день
просто , автомат у меня правило такое
меня рабочий день начинается и амиду
встречи с 10 30
ты закажешь и шестью часами все позже не
делу рабочий мрачным делаю почему потому
что утром я утра я посвящаю себе это я
языке либо
козин внедряю либо планированием
занимаясь либо ходьба там с либо спорта
неважно вот и есть у меня приложение
которое управляет привычками вот эти
рутинные каждодневно дела лучше всего
перевести в привычке
вот это очень интересно потому что
многие вещи мы делаем на автопилоте
поэтому чем бороться с плохими
привычками
гораздо эффективнее внедрять новые
привычки если ты внедряешь полезные
привычки ты уделяешь больше внимания
этому больше энергию автоматически ты
начинаешь забывать плохие привычки
потому что в дни представьте день как
труба и в его ширина 24 часа вы хоть
запланируете вы не впихнуть и туда
больше дел вам по-любому 8 часов спать
вам по-любому столько часов уходит на
гигиену столько-то часов на еду и так
далее и вот этот остаток речь идет о том
что вот эту одну четверть или одну треть
проводить вот так все остальное сон не
надо планировать летами другое про что
многие вещи привычки надо
автоматизировать
второе делать отдельную доску для
сложных проектов но не знаю
строительство дома
условно это проект целый проект
строительства дома и вот вы там его
нельзя вот так и раскидает разбить вы
назовите проект строительства дома и там
нам сделать проект давай говори с
проводом со строителя
вот это купить материалы и так далее и
так далее и он будет вот так
самостоятельно жить но просто когда вот
это стекло сегодня вы для себя
определите что сегодня стол без только
вот этот у тебя потому что не можете
одеть 8 часов рабочего времени здесь 816
она не может так ты просто отсюда берешь
часть сюда кидаешь а просто вот с
нижнего проект суда а потом отсюда
сделано это по дому на дачу сделать
договориться с прорабом к этом процессе
меч на моей стороне вот это я забанил
что-то через неделю привязать шифер вот
это вот это я буду делать сегодня но
сегодня вы вот это уберите вас столбец
сегодня общей потому что вы вот этими
столбцами играть можете но сегодня 24
часа в сутки всего лишь это вот эта
бутылочное горлышко и вот здесь сегодня
и этого сыграет от того что вы туда не
на пихаете слишком много делать это вот
как управлять всего три варианта есть
первое рутинные дела это через привычки
и через вот это планирование которая
автоматом каждый день второе это все
наши основные дела до 8 процентов
времени и 3 когда у вас есть сложные
проекты
вы можете таким образом но я так что же
у меня есть еще я для себя сделал такую
вещь так как у меня на айфоне
предложи называется тревор я там сделал
еще
встречи и публикации фейсбуке они всего
две доски но там очень мало таких
столбцов для чего не бывает так то я
открываю вот и это надо с этим 300 над
этим надо с этим надо с этим а там кучу
встреч куча событий надо на том
мероприятии календарь это надо не спеша
сесть раскидать это со всеми согласовать
кто-то хочет в один и тот же день и так
далее то есть целая такая работа поэтому
я просто как ящик встречи туда кидаю
когда когда когда я потом когда время я
сажусь и так начинают так с этим лучше
встретиться завтра пишу ему вот так
давай завтра с этим будут встретили
едут все расписал и переношу карточки в
процессе на месячной автор не
исполнителя потом когда они ответили я
вот это беру вечно на моей стороне и уже
в календарь прописываю во столько-то
часов кафиру вот там в кафе поль три
часа от в офисе во столько-то и все
расписано но это в том случае когда вот
мне просто сыпется вот эти все
предложения проекты и так далее и так
далее они вот здравствуй ехал на субботу
воскресенье блин там вот так насыпалось
и надо же этого всю поэтому это
отдельный процесс
я его вывел выделил отдельно доску
назвал встречи или бывает еще одна доска
у меня
публикации фейсбуке бывает вот так хочет
ушибленной про вот это публиковать а
когда опубликовать когда подготовить
текст картинки цифры не знаешь ну просто
на главная мысль этого планирования
заключается в том чтобы всегда держать
голову пустой вот только появилась надо
вот это публиковать я сразу карточку за
мужу
потом придумал когда опубликовать что я
просто буду на что это нужно
опубликовать
карточка это зеркало всех ваших мыслей и
когда вы вот так вкладывайте вы на самом
деле раскладываете всю работу вашего
мозга и глазами как бы со стороны видите
что вы делаете как вы делаете когда
делайте как быстро вы делаете что вам
мешает вот у меня есть например
несколько огорчить который постоянно
кочует из нужно сделать в январе потом
опять нужно сделать феврале потом нужно
сделать mark 3 раз так происходит я
сажусь я думал вообще это мне нужно или
так себе думал навязал сам себе что вот
нужно
и потом часто бывает так что окажется
просто хотел бы бывает хочу
а на самом деле не хочу ну в статистика
пока что я по факту не хочу сейчас прям
я вам покажу как это делаю я электронном
виде вот например давай создадим carbon
2008-го 18 года они не сразу за они друг
друга дополняют вот trello мы начали
старела
вот команда 2018 года теперь делай
канбан делает нужно сделать запланирован
сделано теперь выйди опять в доски доски
и создай новую доску carbon апреля
например сделай нужно сделать
запланировано процессе мяч на стороне
исполнителя
процессе мяч на моей стороне дальше
сегодня и сделаны возвращаемся в доску
18 года зайди в доску 8 вот компом 18
года давайте напишем например выучить 10
букв алфавита вот так выучит 9 10 букв
выучить вторые 10 букв выучить третье
здесь мы вот теперь это нужно сделать
теперь снизу карточку комбо 18 года
научиться считать
на арабском следующая карточка
научиться читать на арабском выучить 100
арабских слов
выучить вторую сотню арабки слов выучить
третью вот смотрите мы создали доску 18
года такая же доска писать вот мы
создали карточки
теперь выучить 10 букв карина покажи как
это делать кидается запланировано ведь
вы берете дракон true просто берете
переносит также как физическую теперь
давайте бросим в апреле
открой вот перевести канбан апреля вот
он в компании апреля куда перенести в
нужно сделать в запланировали в процессе
или этого нужно сделать перенесен 10
букв здесь все перенесена привет всем и
с 18-го года на апрель кинули
теперь заявив доску апреля доска прям
видите вот они появились всего теперь ты
говоришь так нужно сегодня вы учитесь
букв перейти на сегодня раз бросил
выучил кидает вы учитесь муки кидать на
сделаны новые 10 букв
например запланируем на следующей неделе
ты хочешь вот бросил теперь откроет
самую карточку вы учитесь быку откроет
смотрите здесь что может есть но это для
навороченных участники вы можете всю
команду sudo зарезать кому-то поручать
он будет видеть там вот метки вот чек
лист вот делает и добавить чеклист
вот когда сложные эти проекты например
можно сделать вот так не выучить 10 букв
а иногда и дело так выучить алфавит
вроде большой кусок да а потом я просто
в чек-листе
сюда добавляю выучить 10 букв
добавить выучить 10 букв а мне надо
писать вторые 10 3 просто выучить 10
буквы учитесь сурок поставь до до конца
апреля
вот я ставлю срок сохранить теперь
закрой 1 вот эту карточку
сегодня перекида на сегодня то есть
условно говоря кастрюлю с пельменями
перевожу открываю выучить сегодня когда
я выучил что-то я беру чек-лист сюда
нажимаем ок все 1 десятка закрывая
карточку все этот день закончился я
выучить алфавит опять назад возвращаем я
сразу из трех
делу я одну уже там внутри сделал модно
теперь когда мне опять то алфавит нужно
это я беру его кидают сегодня как
выполнил опять там галочку поставил
опять верну потом когда 33 раза отметить
набрать третий раз сегодня выучил все
закончил я когда сделано
ведь получается зеленое 30 пришли значит
я выполнил во время до даты до дедлайна
до 30 апреля trello полностью заменяет
вот это все что я вам покажу
полностью самое главное вы должны четко
держать голове каждая мысль и твоя
карточка
нету мысли нету карточки появилась новая
мысль появилась новая карточка второе
софт который я использую и the ultimate
календарь это дорогие в appstore
вот здесь вот видите он для смартфона
поэтому здесь мы покажем просто
скриншоты смотрите что вот вот здесь я
уже раскладываю по дням здесь у меня
сразу видеть разных цветов
сразу видно это хобби бизнес социальные
и общественные лай так далее так далее
но это изучите это уже как обычный
календар но он работает когда я работаю
с январю
планируя dwar встречи с кем назначить во
сколько здесь время dice может смотреть
день неделя месяц год может смотреть по
часам по задачам по спискам если
например вы синие присвоили бизнесу или
фиолетовый вот и сразу вас видно 13
часов вас по бизнес бизнес встречах 14
15 16 встреч и вот она вот здесь
полосочкой за показ бизнес-встреч
зеленая стена привет там что-то другое
вот сразу определенным и сразу это на
месяц и сразу видно сколько у вас бизнес
речь сколько у вас общественно дело
сколько семейных дел сколько это сразу
видно теперь третье это в офлайн вот
здесь вы чё делаете вы вот здесь вы вот
здесь нажимаете пишите какие вот
привычка хотим ретвить и выпить воды
медитация никакой газировки никакого
алкоголя и так далее и когда в течение
вот вы берете раз нажимаете он
высвечивается вот это да нет пропустить
или не выполнил ты просто выполнил не
выполнил и тыр-тыр-тыр и вот видно ты
пропустил тренировку в этот день это
потом показывать в графиках потом ты
хочешь внедрить но в эту например сюда
внедряешь не есть сахар после 1500 там
не смешно и после 1500 и вот раз ты раз
заходишь после 15 00 мышиного не имел
отмечаются галочку зеленым вот это да у
тебя так и ты видишь сколько дней подряд
ты уже без мучного ты видишь сколько
дней подряд и ты увидишь
я сорвался и так далее ну это
планировщик для рутинных дел которые
ежедневные
а потом вы видите он дает такой динамика
в течение шести недель сколько раз ты
выполнял сколько раз не выполняла очень
просто там вот там мозгов вообще
включать не надо ты там в день 10-12
привычек забил который ты должен
выполнить каждый день и там вопрос дании
дании да нет у меня вот утром встал в
шесть часов не стал ясно же ясно отмечаю
встал дальше выпил воды ну добавки не
выпил тоже ясно выпил хорошо прогулку
сделал не сделал ясно смотрите у вас все
получается сон потом гигиенические
мероприятия туалет там помыться то все
потом у вас получается вред время
продуктивно из этого путин времени в
этот часть надо отдать привычкам и не
думать ни о них вообще один раз для себя
привычку установил вот это установили да
нет да нет да нет да нет да нет все
а потом вас остается вот эта верхняя
часть и его раскладываете вот таким
образом все ясно вот 3 приложения они не
конкурируют друг с другом одно для
управления привычками
одно для управления вот этой вашей
жизнью одно но для управления ваш в
течение дня
система команда она выстраивается всегда
так что есть продавец покупатель вот эта
у каждого процесса это же принцип
продавец покупателя например если что-то
сделал но нужно сделать например какой
то проект ты его делаешь для кого
для кого-то же ты вот условном даже не
пригодилось ты говоришь я сделал
отправляешь он проверяет горит нет не
пойдет на задке целой то есть надо
систему сделать так что внутри всегда
продавец покупатель был
и тогда не надо контроле it вот основной
принцип козин гласит то что нельзя
переносить
брак на следующий этап и последующий
процесс является клиентом предыдущего
процесс в данном случае вот у нас тоже
вот смотрите даже внутри себя
вот этот процесс является клиентом вот
этого процесса потому что все суда подаю
потом отсюда сюда падает и вот в
процессе на мяч на мастер не или кожи
идентифицирует ответом если это от кого
другого зависит теперь мой мяч на чужой
стороне есть этим вообще не занимаешься
пока бросил сюда если запланировано дата
конкретно вот сюда если сегодня
конкретно делаешь вот сюда то есть эта
система что хорошо она нет серых
полутонов нету и избегая сомнительного
нету сомнительного а вот если в
командной работе то просто так
выстраивается так что когда ты ему
задачу кидаешь там есть три вещи 3
участника
заказчик и исполнитель и контролер
получается вот часто бывает такая
ситуация вот видите вот бывает бывает
юрист выполняет но ему дал задачу
начальник your отделы
а составные контроллер бухгалтер потому
что для нее это делается
они в конечном итоге договор еду есть
такие системы много
весь важно дать вот то что я дал сегодня
основу потому что уровень детализации ни
у одного из вас не совпадёт
я же расскажу как кто-то любит такие
пельмешки кто-то любит манты кто-то
любит пирог как я показал на примере
арабского языка алфавит но внутри
чик-чик лист маленькие куски пирога есть
то есть разные люди по-разному масштаб
задачу в банане у разных людей разная
производительность кто-то может там 15
пельмени в день сьесть а кто-то 3 то
есть это чисто индивидуальная главное
дала вам основу
а дальше в или гулять в какой-то день у
вас более энергии высоко приехали вы
можете вот столько задачу помню в какой
день вы можете там три задачу по 2
задача одну вообще ничего не делать но
самое главное вы не вы раб системы а вы
хозяин системы вот это очень важно когда
у вас есть список что сделает обычно
систем планировки наступила да да
дедлайн все ты должен делать хочешь не
хочешь есть либо энергия не эту энергии
после отпуска допуска пофиг а эта
система все учитывает козин полезен
исходит и здравого смысла и увеличит
эффективность и счастье каждого человека
будь то предприятие будто завод будь то
дом будет уход личная жизнь казино
работает везде поэтому моя мечта чтобы к
один центр был во всех городах
казахстана
поэтому я буду продолжать давать
семинары такие мастер классы в на
платной основе только для того чтобы
опять таки помогать кайден центру к 1
вообще это наука которая сугубо
практичная и to me up нету тела берлин
теория минимум здесь вот деловые игры и
тренажеры в российской один клуб
все энтузиасты там собираются и мы
обсуждаем каждом этаже мне моя частная
наука это наука
достояние человечества и что каждый вот
смотрите в интернете ищите интересуетесь
это как у
эффективности нету конца и
совершенствовать такие как вы будете вот
будь вот до такого уровня супер к денису
вас новые горизонты потом еще еще это
вечно
и вечно вечно но просто на каждом этапе
вы будете получать такое бешеное
удовлетворение такое удовольствие от
жизни внедряя кайтен и самое интересное
что козин он построен таким образом все
что ты сделал ты уже к этому не
возвращаешься
если ты что-то внедрил его туда уже не
возвращаюсь пока ты все сегодня вывел на
эту рынками потом опять выброс 6 по 2 мг
руб улучшающий вот так и
корзину можно подвергнуть все
человеческие отношения
бизнес-планирования там вот все что
мыслимо даже родственные отношения все
можно подъезд к кайден в общая понимая
это постоянно непрерывное улучшение
разве я что-то что невозможно улучшить
все можно улучшить и отношении в том
числе поэтому вас добро пожаловать в
казань центр спасибо что прошли на
сегодняшний мастер-класс
надеюсь я оправдал тех денег которые вы
заплатили
[аплодисменты]
теперь снимаем аппаратуру